[Music]
foreign
I want you to know to start with that I
never wanted it to come to this but I
have been left with no choice I must
today cancel my friend and colleague
Michael Knowles of course I've known for
a long time that Michael is not a
believer in Aliens I've listened to him
repeatedly slander the alien believer
Community ABC and I have shown great and
admirable restraint choosing not to
respond in kind but now he has crossed a
line so for a little bit of background
uh and behind the scenes here yesterday
as I was passing Michael in the hallway
on the way to to film my show after he
had just filmed his he excitedly shouted
to me hey I talked about aliens today
he was baiting me to watch the segment
and I took the bait I was expecting it
to be ignorant and factually Incorrect
and it lived up to those expectations or
down to them but I did not expect the
level of vitriol and hate that I
encountered
he launched a vicious defamatory
broadside against the entire ABC even
calling me out by name which means he's
attacking the ABC and the SBG the ABC
SBG he stopped short of saying that we
should be eradicated but I know he was
thinking it you know there's been a cold
war over the alien issue at the daily
wire for years now
but now Michael Knowles is firing shots
uh here's the clip
another story I had to get to today
this is out of UCI
the University of California Irvine
Terminator zones on distant planets
could Harbor life
you see Irvine astronomers say
these in between regions could be prime
sites for liquid water
in a new study University of California
Irvine astronomers describe how
extraterrestrial life has the potential
to exist on distant exoplanets inside a
special area called The Terminator Zone
which is a ring on planets that always
have one side facing its star on one
side that's always in the dark
and the thing is
um
no they couldn't
the thing is I'm not even going to read
the rest of the article I'm certainly
not going to read the study
uh no the Terminator zones could not
Harbor life because extraterrestrial
aliens aren't real they're not real and
the limbs just they love it they were so
fascinated by it it's just it made me
think
about how many completely ridiculous
things the libs believe in and yet they
call us the gullible ones they call us
the Fantastical ones
the libs believe in catastrophic global
warming is going to kill us all in five
minutes the libs believe that boys can
secretly be girls and girls can secretly
be boys and the libs believe
in E.T it's not real there is
I know this is controversial on the
right I know my colleague Matt Walsh
here is very Pro ET there is
zero evidence
that extraterrestrial life exists
anywhere
zero the the best evidence they can
musterers well the universe is really
big okay yeah
okay first of all why are you reading
off of an actual piece of paper this is
the year 2023 what are you trying to
prove do you do show research with the
Dewey Decimal System too I mean I
believe in returning to tradition but
let's be serious here
second
I don't know why I'm asking about shell
research it's clear on this topic anyway
they don't believe in research you claim
that there's no good reason to believe
in alien life but then refuse to read
anything that might threatened to
explode your bigoted
ETI phobic preconceived notions that
study from UCI which you printed out and
then discarded literally murdering trees
for no reason says that planets orbiting
red dwarf stars could it in fact have
the right conditions to Harbor life now
this is significant because it vastly
expands the number of extrasolar planets
that could potentially have life you're
correct that the size of the universe
does not itself indicate that there's
life elsewhere in the universe indeed if
we lived in a vast Universe hundreds of
trillions of light years across and
there were no other planets and we could
assume that aliens aren't real as you
say but in fact we do live uh we do not
live in an endless vacuum with only one
planet orbiting one solitary star we
live in an endless vacuum with billions
of planets orbiting billions of stars
the existence of the planets
doesn't prove that the planets are
inhabited obviously and we know just
based on chemical composition and
atmospheric conditions that a large
portion of them are almost certainly not
inhabited but that still leaves billions
of planets where the potential for Life
exists each planet is potential and that
potential is repeated billions upon
billions of times you say there's no
evidence of eut that's that's true in
the sense that we haven't seen like an
alien skyscraper through a telescope or
whatever but we can calculate the number
of potentially habitable planets and
that number goes up all the time so
there's evidence of et's potential and
that potential is repeated in
essentially infinite number of times
it's possible that you could visit every
planet in every solar system in every
Galaxy and even after spending trillions
of years on that sightseeing tour still
find not one living species anywhere
else that's possible but it's not the
most likely scenario
okay you certainly have no rational
basis for assuming it and you definitely
have no rational or evidentiary grounds
for declaring from the outset that
there's nothing to find in the first
place
by way of analogy consider this you know
we now know that there are something
like 3.5 trillion fish living in the
oceans 500 years ago we knew very little
about what lived there people came up
with all kinds of wild theories many of
which ended up being incorrect but the
sheer size of the ocean
was evidence in itself that it probably
contained billions and trillions of
living creatures
uh so yes the fact that the ocean was
big was reason enough to
speculate that there's probably billions
and trillions of fish in it that was an
assumption that could be reasonably made
and it would have been irrational and
ridiculous for a person 500 years ago to
assume that the ocean only contains the
number of fish that he can see when he
stands on the shore and looks out that's
what you're doing in essence you're
standing on the shoreline and saying
well I see a horseshoe crab and a clam I
guess that's all there is and if
everybody was standing on that Shoreline
with you and nobody had seen any more of
the ocean then we would have to admit
that your assumption could prove correct
but even without checking we would still
know that it is not the most plausible
Theory
yet you're doing something more absurd
here because you're standing billions of
miles away and declaring that all of the
oceans and all of the land on all of the
planets and all of the solar systems in
all of the galaxies are all empty
now
let us examine the charge which you make
later in the clip
uh that and and you're making what we
heard there that I am a lib on this
issue I will concede that whoever is the
most is most the lib when it comes to
the question of alien life is the least
likely to be correct there is of course
an inverse correlation between liveness
and correctness you say that I'm the lid
because uh because you know Libs want to
believe that human beings aren't special
and uh and that could be achieved by
postulating the existence of other
beings in the universe
but that is not my position
no I can't speak for the actual Libs who
may or may not believe in alien life but
what I can say for myself is that I know
human beings are special because we were
made by God and we have rational Souls I
also know that God has chosen to place
the human species inside this in fact
unfathomably boundless Universe
populated by something like 700
quintillion planets they create all
these planets and all these galaxies the
vast majority of which we will never see
not even in a telescope only to keep
them all empty
possible I suppose but he also may have
created them in order to fill them with
life which will glorify him in ways that
we perhaps will never understand I would
submit that insisting on an empty
universe is an attempt to limit God it
is to say that God must operate in ways
that we understand and that he cannot
have created an other life on other
planets because the existence of such
lies life raises questions that are
uncomfortable for us
this I would say is Huber's as for the
specialness of human beings
why would humans be less special just
because other life exists is each
individual human less special just
because there are eight billion of us
there there were 400 million people on
Earth 500 years ago today there are 8
billion has our individual stocks
somehow gone down just because we now
find ourselves on a planet far more
popular than anyone in the 16th century
ever could have imagined no not at all
and so if I am not worth any less no
matter how many people live on Earth how
would I be worth any less by the
addition of life on planets I will never
visit or see anyway
human beings are not Commodities whose
worth is determined by the law of supply
and demand the universe
could be teeming with life and I believe
it very well may be and that would not
undermine our Worth or our purpose by
one iota
we have our place on this vast Cosmic
tapestry even if that tapestry is far
more alive and vibrant than you assume
and that assumption that assumption if
anything
makes you a lib sir and a scoundrel
and it also makes you today
canceled
that'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block you can become a member today and
use code walls to check out for two
months for you on all annual plans hope
to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]